i hate intros dr stone season one
episode one we kick things off at a high
school where a bunch of students
including the main character
senku ishigami look on as one of their
classmates goes to confess his love
taiji oki is the brave soul about to put
his heart on the line in front of
everyone
and in the other corner the recipient of
his imminent love confession is
yuzuriya ogawa as he goes to take the
plunge there's a bright green light and
suddenly everybody in the world is
turned to stone
3700 years pass by and all taiju can
think about the entire time is being
able to nail yuzuriya he is finally able
to break free from his petrified state
and he finds
the brainiac senku had already broken
free senku had woke up six months
earlier and already set the foundation
for decent living conditions
now that he has the strong kaiju around
to help him out they can continue
rebuilding civilization
the two work hard at finding a cure to
the petrification and after one year
they succeed in creating this revival
fluid using some miracle water and bat
guano
ye episode they make enough revival
fluid to free one person and we all know
who ties you once so they go to use it
on yuzuriya taiju's kind of paper and
doesn't want her to be naked when she
wakes up so instead of just throwing
something over the top of her they
decide hey let's stall things out until
we get chased by lions
they're too weak and can't fight the
lions so they decide that they need to
use the fluid on sukasa shishio
who was supposed to be a really strong
fighter turns out this guy's like
superman and tarzan had a goddamn baby
so he one taps one of the lions and
chases the others off
the three continue working together each
pulling their own weight and the things
that they're good at taiji was then sent
by senku to collect some seashells so
that they can grind them into calcium
carbonate for a variety of reasons that
i don't remember then one day tsukasa
reveals another side of himself when he
breaks one of the petrified people
essentially killing a man
he says that this is a new world and
they should only wake up good people not
people who are going to corrupt it
senku challenges him on this idea
stating that he's going to work to free
every person he can
episode three after figuring out that
sukkos is kind of [ __ ] crazy and
wants to kill the majority
of the population which he's already
started doing by destroying tons of
bodies
senku takes measures against him he
pretends like he messed up getting
revival fluid and tsukasa volunteers to
go get some more
mostly just so he can find the source of
the fluid for his own selfish use
while he's away senko reveals that he
actually has more revival fluid and they
quickly use it to wake up yuzuriya
the three of them try to stand up to
tsukasa but they can clearly see that
they don't stand a chance
even with senko's scuffed crossbow which
proves to be useless
tsukasa surprisingly doesn't do anything
serious about this he just says to stay
out of his way and proceeds to destroy
more statues giving the others the
chance to plot their next move they make
it look like they fled and wind up
coming across the great buddha of
kamakura which they use
as a landmark to guide them to hakone
once they come across a volcanic hot
spring senku implements his plan to make
a jump in their technology
and create a gun to stop tsukasa
episode four thank you is successful in
making his first batch of gunpowder but
then taiju accidentally ignites it and
causes a small explosion
the smoke from the explosion is seen as
a smoke signal from other possible
survivors and they send up a smoke
signal of their own knowing there's a
risk of giving their position away to
tsukasa
senku decides to send up more smoke
signals tsukasa closes in on them in no
time and takes yuzuriya hostage while
taiji is out gathering wood for the
signals he threatens to kill her unless
senku gives him the recipe to the
revival fluid
she is more than happy to give up her
life in order to keep senku alive
because as long as he knows the recipe
and tsukasa does it he can't kill senku
good guys senku decides it's not worth
her life and he tells you cause of the
recipe
in order to guarantee her safety now
that he knows the recipe he no longer
has any reason to keep senko alive so he
prepares to kill him in the last scene
episode five senku was supposedly killed
by tsukasa after he dealt a fatal blow
to his neck
as taiju returns tsukasa thinks that he
could retaliate so he prepares to kill
him as well he throws a rock up which
draws the attention of sukasa thinking
he was launching an attack but the real
attack would be coming from yuzuriya
she throws all the gunpowder that senku
had made at sukasa and when the rock
lands it causes an explosion that gives
them the distance they need to grab
senku's body and make a run for it
figuring that senku had to have had a
plan they realized that there was a
piece of petrification still on senku's
neck
they hoped that by pouring some of the
revival fluid on it maybe he could be
brought back
we then get a flashback of when senku
had very first woke up in the stone
world it shows his first days of
learning how to hunt gather and craft
everything he would need while being
constantly judged by some douchebag
monkeys
episode 6. still in our flashback senku
realized that he needed some brawn to
his brain so when he managed to find
taiji he works on anything he could
think of to bring him back
anyways back up to the present where the
revival fluid works and seku was brought
back despite his injuries making him
even more curious as to how the
regenerative properties worked
after trying to come up with a new plan
senku decides that since sukasa thinks
he's dead the best course of action
would be for them to split up taiji and
yuzuru will go and infiltrate sukasa's
camp as spies in order to keep an eye on
what he's up to
meanwhile senkou will start looking for
the people that sent up the other smoke
signals in hopes that they can form a
resistance of science against sukasa
jump on over to tsukasa who gets
attacked by a new face
the cutie chan kohaku who had seen what
he had did to senku while he was trying
to protect yuzuriya she tries bringing
sucasa to justice by killing him but he
manages to knock a tree on top of her
ending the fight
senkou saw the commotion from a distance
and when he gets there he finds the pin
kohaku
using a block and tackle he manages to
lift the tree off of her and sets her
free possibly laying the foundation to a
glorious harem
episode seven kohaku takes senko back to
her village of 40 people where they're
not allowed inside because outsiders are
forbidden from entering that's when we
meet the guards protecting the village
kinro and
ginro who are vigilant about keeping
senku out we get another new face in the
self-proclaimed sorcerer named chrome
who was a scuffed
stone age scientist he challenges senku
to see who can make the superior sorcery
which clearly senku dumpsters him out
[Music]
and after that the two become friends
chrome makes senku realize that no
matter how hard tsukasa tries there is
no preventing the inevitability of more
scientific minds like chrome senku also
learns that the reason chrome had taken
up the scuff sciences aka sorcery is
because kohaku's sister ruri is sick
with an unknown disease
this makes senku explain what the world
used to be like and the advancements of
the previous world this explanation
segues into him agreeing to help save
ruby's life by making the first
antibiotics
episode 8 senku employs the help of
kohaku and chrome to start gathering the
necessary supplies
in order to make the antibiotics well at
working they come across one of the
villagers named suika who is wearing a
melon on her head
because she wears the melon no one ever
has any use for her in the village so
she just wants to help out
senku is of course more than happy to
get all the help he can and this is also
the first time
someone didn't care about the melon on
her head so suika goes full try hard
mode the four of them are trying to turn
iron scent into iron
but they don't have enough manpower
since the villagers are the only
candidates for recruitment they send
suica into the village using her
incognito mode to gain more info on how
to win them over
after hearing chubster talk about
wanting different food setgu decides
that's how he's gonna win them
over he uses his knowledge to create the
first bowl of ramen which to him is
disgusting compared to the old world
ramen but everyone else thinks it's the
food of the gods
next step is to set up a ramen cart just
outside the village enticing the
villagers to come and try his new
creation
episode 9. the roman gig is a huge hit
and a lot of villagers fall in love with
the flavors
everything seems to be going as planned
and then we meet a new phase again
asagori
gen is a magician from the old world and
was set free by sukasa
sukasa had task again with going and
confirming that senku was actually
killed but after seeing all the
impressive things that senku was capable
of coming up with he considers changing
teams
in order to keep sukasa off senku's
trail he says that he's going to give
him a false report
saying that senku was never found ken is
brought in to be a part of the workforce
and the gang successfully creates iron
after a thunderstorm rolls in senku
jumps into action to take advantage of
the lightning in order to make
magnets genn also proves to be somewhat
useful by warding off a potential fight
with the villagers
using some elementary magic tricks
having used the lightning to create some
magnets they go on to use them to build
a power generator
it convinced the guards kinro and ginro
to operate the generator which leads to
the light bulb being reinvented
episode 10. while talking they learned
that genn still hasn't fully aligned
with senku because he just wants to look
out for his own best interests even if
that means siding with sukasa
we then get a quick flashback of when
genn was first revived by tsukasa
he had collected a lot of people that he
deemed worthy of saving into one spot
and genn was one of them
genn was then given the task of going
out and confirming senku's death shortly
after
well out by himself at night genn is
suddenly attacked but can't get a good
look at the assailant
after the attack suica volunteers
herself and her incognito mode to find
out what had happened from the villagers
while
everybody else tends to his wounds suika
comes back with the information that the
man who came looking for a fight during
the storm
named magma was the one responsible
magma's goal
is to win the grand bout which would
allow him to marry rory and become
village chief he casually says out loud
that he doesn't want the hassle of
dealing with a sickly wife and plans on
framing her suicide once he's chief
apparently everybody's [ __ ] deaf
except for kohaku but then kohaku
doesn't tell anybody because she's
[ __ ] stupid she instead decides that
she needs to defeat him at the previous
grand battle and prevents the marriage
they decide that they're just going to
have to beat him again in this grand
battle so kohaku trains with quinro and
guinro in order to compete
and protect ruri meanwhile despite his
injuries genn makes his way back to
sukasa who has started putting together
a group of formidable allies
gen goes on to tell sukasu that senku
was confirmed dead
and in exchange for this senku had
agreed to make him a cola
episode 11. suica was diagnosed with the
blurry sickness which is really just her
being nearsighted
and the helmet helps her see a bit
better after learning this senku uses
quartzan to make glass
and turns it into glasses for suica
allowing her to see the world clearly
for the first time
seku then turns his focus to making
glass lab materials to drive their
progress forward
the only problem is that none of them
can glass blow the material properly
chrome is forced to employ the craftsman
kasuki against his will to help them
even though he's against it at first
because he's holding stuck in his ways
he comes around after seeing them fail
so many times
and makes a collection of beakers for
senku to work with with the kingdom of
science making so many huge strides
senku then sets his sights on making
genre a new silver spear
they then plan to go on a dangerous
venture to get some more materials
episode 12. the silver spear was
supposed to be just a gift to genre but
really it was designed as a tool to
detect poisonous gas
coming from a pool of sulfuric acid they
need to collect some of the sulfuric
acid in order to make the antibiotics
but can't get through the toxic gas
senku designs a gas mask to weather the
gas and allow them to get to the pool
but in the off chance that something
goes wrong he wants chrome to stay
behind so that science doesn't die with
them both groom refuses of course
and convinces him to let him tag along
so they both go to the pool
everything is going well enough until
suddenly chrome slips and falls
luckily genre who initially wanted to
stay behind makes it to chrome just
before he falls into the pool and saves
his life with his spear
despite the near-death experience the
mission was accomplished and they got
what they came for
i'm gonna be doing the future seasons
and you can find out the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the dr stone recaps in the
playlist on the right side you can also
find the links in the description below
and the only thing i hate more than
intros
is outros